[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE COLEMAN: Hi.
I'm Mike Coleman, a Developer
Advocate here at Google Cloud.
In this video, I
want to walk you
through how you can use Google
Cloud's Migrate for Anthos
to move existing Linux
workloads from virtual machines
to containers in
just a few steps.
This video builds
on an earlier one,
Introducing Migrate for Anthos.
If you haven't watched
that video yet,
definitely go check
it out, as this one
assumes you've performed the
prerequisites we outline there.
Building on what you learned
in the first video, let's
jump into an actual migration.
As a brief recap,
Migrate for Anthos
has three primary components.
The discovery tool
assesses how successful
a migration of a given
application might be.
The processing cluster
is a Kubernetes cluster
that is used to
examine the source VM
and create the migration
plan, as well as execute
the actual migration.
And finally, migctl,
a command line tool,
like kubectl, for interacting
with the processing cluster.
We'll do most of our work today
in the Google Cloud Console,
but I will show you
a bit of migctl.
And again, to quickly
recap, a migration
generally consists of
the following steps.
First, create a
Google Cloud project,
set up the necessary
service accounts,
and enable the appropriate APIs.
Then you create a migration
processing cluster.
After that, choose and
qualify your target workload.
Then you define your
migration source,
create a migration plan,
and adjust that plan
to ensure it meets your needs.
After that, you create the
actual deployment artifacts.
And then finally, you can
deploy the newly containerized
application.
The first two steps were
covered in the previous video,
so we'll start by discussing
choosing the right workload.
There are some applications that
are well-suited for migration
and some that are not.
Linux applications that are a
good fit for migration using
Migrate for Anthos include
the following application
architectures-- web and
application servers,
business logic middleware--
for example, Tomcat--
multi-VM, multi-tier
stacks-- for example, lamp--
small and medium
sized databases,
like MySQL and PostgreSQL.
In addition,
applications best suited
for migration with
Migrate for Anthos
have the following
operational characteristics.
They have a low duty-cycle
and bursty workloads,
they're always-on with low
load services, or deployment,
testing, and training-lab
environments.
In general, most Linux workloads
are compatible with migration.
However, there are some
types of workloads that
are not really recommended.
These would include high
performance and large in-memory
databases, VMs with special
kernel drivers-- for example,
kernel-mode NFS--
apps with dependencies
on specific hardware,
and software with licenses
tied to certain hardware ID
registration.
For this demo, I'm using a
Java application housed in a VM
which also has a
Postgres database.
So I have a good feeling
that this application
is an appropriate
candidate to migrate.
But how can I be sure?
Well, we have a
utility for that--
the Migrate for
Anthos discovery tool.
The discovery tool
has two parts.
The first is a collection script
that runs on the source VM
and analyzes the
running application.
The analysis script then looks
at that information gathered
from the collection phase and
gives us a score of 1 to 10
on the likelihood of a
successful migration.
You can run your analysis
script on a centralized server,
allowing you to batch
process collected data.
So let's jump into our demo
and look at the discovery
tool, which I've
already installed
on the source VM running
on Google Compute Engine.
You can consult the
Migrate for Anthos docs
for info on how to
install the tool.
Before we look at
the discovery tool,
I wanted to take a quick
overview of the sample
application we're working with,
which is the Cymbal Bank app.
So I'm going to go ahead, come
down here, and click Sign In.
And what you're
going to see here
is a typical
banking application.
We're looking at the
ledger view here.
I can come up and I
can click Send Payment.
I can choose another
user from the dropdown.
We'll use Alice here.
I'm going to send her $100,
and we're going to click Send.
And you can see
the ledger update.
So everything is working
the way we expect it to.
Let's look a little bit
at how that application
is deployed on the back end.
The application is
actually made up
of a combination of
Kubernetes services
and then a monolithic service
running in a virtual machine.
So on the Kubernetes side, we
have four services running.
They handle everything from
managing the accounts database
to the web front end
we just interacted
with to that dropdown
list that we saw,
where we can pull up
associated accounts
that the main user has.
We come into here.
This is our VM that
we're going to migrate,
and that's the ledger service.
So everything you saw there
that dealt with the ledger, that
is handled here-- so how
do we update the ledger,
check balances,
those sort of things.
The other thing is that this
monolith includes the database,
the ledger database.
So there's an accounts
database and a ledger database,
and the ledger database
lives inside of this VM.
So when we're done, we're
going to have migrated this VM
into a Kubernetes service.
So let's get started with that.
So here I am.
I've SSH'd into that
ledger monolith service VM.
And as I mentioned
before, I've already
installed the Migrate for
Anthos discovery tool,
so what we want to do
here is, let's take a look
at what that's comprised of.
You have the collect script
and the analysis script.
So we're going to go ahead and
run that collect script first.
So let me run that,
and that's going
to produce a TAR file here.
And we're going to go ahead
and then run the analysis
script against that TAR file.
So we'll go ahead and run that.
And then that gives us
a CSV file, and let's
cat out the contents
of that file.
So this is a little hard
to read on the screen.
So what I've done is, I've
actually taken and moved
that CSV onto my local
machine and loaded it up
into a Google Sheet.
There's a lot of
information here.
I'm only going to point
out a couple of things.
First, our fit score is a
9, and that is right here.
So we've got a 9
out of 10, and that
means it's a great fit with
none to very little manual work,
based on the glossary here.
The other thing I
want to point out
is that we do have a
Postgres database in the VM
that the fit tool
discovered, and we'll
have to deal with that
during our migration.
But with a score of 9, we
should feel pretty good
that we should be able to
migrate this application
with very little effort.
So the next step is to actually
create a migration source.
So we're going to do that by
moving back here in the Cloud
Console, and we're going
to go to Anthos, Migrate
to containers.
Remember, we've already set
up our processing cluster.
We did that in our last video.
So the processing
cluster is right here.
So now we're going
to create a source.
So we'll come in and
we'll say Add Source.
And we're going to select
our processing cluster.
Click Next.
We're going to go and
give this source a name.
And it's going to come
from Compute Engine.
Remember, it can come from
VMware or AWS or Azure,
as well, but in this case,
we're using Compute Engine.
We'll click Next.
In the first video,
we created one service
account to actually let
us install the components
on the processing cluster.
And now we're going to
create a second service
account that lets us deal
with that Compute Engine
as a source.
So we will put the Compute
Viewer and the Compute Storage
Admin roles onto
the service account.
We'll click Next, and we'll
go ahead and add the source.
So we come back here.
We have our source all
ready for us to go.
Next, let's move on to
create our migration.
Now one thing to note is
that before I can actually
migrate a VM, I have to stop
it, which I've already done.
I've gone into the
Google Cloud Console
and I've stopped that
ledger service VM,
so it's not running any longer.
With that, I would
come in here now
and I click Create Migration.
I take the migration name,
and I'll give it a name here.
We'll come down and
we'll select the source
that we just created,
Linux operating system.
And the virtual machine ID
is ledgermonolith-service, so
right there.
And we're going to migrate
both the image and data.
In this case, that monolith
VM has Postgres running in it,
so we need both the
application code and the data.
So let's click Create Migration.
This will take a
couple of minutes,
so I'll fast forward
the video, and I'll
rejoin you when it's done.
Our migration plan
has been generated.
So the next step here
is now to make sure
that migration plan is accurate
for what we want to do.
So we can come
here into Options,
and we can Review and
edit the migration plan.
Now I know one thing I'm
going to need to change
is, down here
under data volumes,
I need to go ahead and tell it
that I want to use the Postgres
folder, right?
So we're going to point it
at that Postres subdirectory,
because remember, we have
that database running there
in our monolithic VM.
So with that, I can save this
and generate my artifacts.
So let's click Save
and Generate Artifacts.
And it'll save it, and it'll
start generating the artifacts.
Again, this will take
a couple of minutes,
so I'll pause the
video, and I'll
rejoin you when it finishes.
So the migration has
completed, and our artifacts
have been generated.
I can click on the
link of the migration
here, and click on
the Artifacts tab,
and you can get a
list of all of them.
So we have a Docker file, but
the Docker image has actually
already been
created and uploaded
to Container Registry
for us, so we don't
need to do anything with that.
What we really care about
is this deployment spec.
Now there's a couple
of ways you can
grab the deployment spec
or any of the artifacts
for that matter.
One is they're stored
in a storage bucket
up on Google Cloud
Storage, and you
could download them from here.
The other way to do it is to
use migctl, the command line
utility, and that's
what we're going to do.
So I'm going to move
over into Cloud Shell,
and I'm going to issue a
migctl migration get-artifacts
command, and that's going to
download the artifacts for me.
So let me go ahead
here and I'll list out
the deployment_spec.yaml, just
to verify it got downloaded.
And that's a standard
Kubernetes yaml
file for deploying the
service and some other stuff.
We're not going to spend a
lot of time going into that.
But what we are going to do
now is actually apply it.
Now the processing cluster is
different from the production
cluster where I run
my applications.
So I need to
actually authenticate
into that production cluster.
So let me go ahead and
issue the gcloud command
to authenticate into
my production cluster,
and we will list out
the nodes, just to make
sure I have the right cluster.
And I do.
So the next step is to actually
just do a kubectl minus f apply
and apply the deployment spec.
And that's going to
create a stateful set.
It's going to create a
service, a Persistent Volume,
and a Persistent Volume Claim.
The Persistent Volume and
the Persistent Volume Claim
will be used to handle that
Postgres database we migrated
over from our monolith VM.
The next thing we need to do
is ensure all of the services
can find each other.
The Cymbal Bank app
does this through a set
of configuration variables.
Currently, the variables
associated with the ledger
service are pointing to the
Compute Engine internal DNS
name of the ledger
monolith VM, which
has the format of
instance name dot
c dot project ID dot internal,
which you can see right here.
I'm going to swap those out
for the Kubernetes service
name, which is simply
ledgermonolith-service.
And if I list my
Kubernetes services,
you can see that service
listed right here.
So the next thing to do is
actually apply that config map,
so those new service
mappings take place.
So we'll apply the
config map here.
Next, let's go ahead and
delete all the existing pods,
and that will force them to
pick up the new mappings when
they regenerate.
And after that, what
we're going to do
is we're going to
list our services,
so we can grab the IP
address of our front end,
and check out and make
sure the application
is still working as expected.
So I'll copy this.
I'm going to paste it
up here into my browser.
So the Cymbal Bank,
the app has loaded.
Let's sign in again.
So we're signed in.
Here's the ledger.
Let's go and do a send
payment to Alice again.
Let's give her $250 this
time, and we'll click Send.
And we can see, the
ledger is updated.
So our application
is working exactly
as we expect it to after
a successful migration.
So there you have it.
In this video, you learned
about using Migrate for Anthos
to move Linux workloads
into containers, including
how to assess your application,
create the migration plan,
execute the migration,
and deploy your newly
containerized application.
Be sure to like and
subscribe, because we'll
be posting subsequent
videos in this series
to cover topics such
as best practices
for evaluating your application,
how to migrate Windows
workloads, and more.
To get started Migrate
for Anthos today,
visit
cloud.google.com/migrate/anthos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]